and the support support from fans is is
massive I mean you can really feel it a
difference in in just to the mood when
when you've got a home crowd cheering
from you or cheering for you or if even
if you're away somewhere and you just
have one person stands out of the crowd
and really sort of eggs you are in it
it's a great feeling and yeah it's it is
definitely something that I'd say lifts
you when especially when when you're
struggling and I'd have to I'd have to
choose month on - from 2013 I can't
remember exactly what stage it was but
it was on Bastille Day in France
obviously the big French public holiday
and the French riders are desperate to
get in the break and win that stage and
it finished up on top of month on - and
it was just I was protecting the yellow
jersey I didn't really have intentions
of going after the stage win but that
the stage should have just panned out in
a way that coming into the last couple
ka I realized it was possible I could I
could win the stage as well and it's
just such a such an amazing feeling I
had my wife I pull up on the top waiting
for me and it just it was yeah was at of
the stage I will stay with me for the
rest of my life
um definitely again the tours is going
to be the main objective for next year
having said that I I don't think I can
really write off the other two grand
tours I think if I look at what I'd like
to leave behind just with my legacy if
you like once once once I'm done with my
career and look back I I would like to
look back and say that I've also given
the other ground towards a good go so
I'm certainly not going to write off the
joy of world safer for one of these
seasons I think one of my favorite
certainly one of my favorite places to
ride is in the Pyrenees I just love the
the raw nature of the Pyrenees it just
feels a lot more untouched than a lot of
other places we ride and it just it's
it's it's tough terrain I mean the the
Pyrenees are steep it's it's pretty
pretty brutal out there but it's it's
just somewhere I really enjoy
[Applause]
one of my favorite products from the SAS
range is the the way 20 protein gel
especially on long training rides and
you don't necessarily want to be taking
a shaker and and powder to to have to
mix with water and everything else it's
it's a it's a good protein top-up when
when you're on the road and tastes good
and pretty pretty easy to to get down
[Applause]
the Tour de France in 2017 is going to
be a tricky tricky addition a really
tough tough challenge for me given the
run many summit finishes and there also
aren't it's very very low in time-trial
kilometers as well so there aren't many
opportunities to really make a
difference in the race but there are
three summit finishes and from from my
point of view efforts really try and
make those three summit finishes count
[Applause]
I don't quite simply I I switch off
completely so come the end of end of my
season I just completely stop thinking
about performance and trying to be the
best I can be every day and just let
myself let myself go let myself live
normally for best part of a month so I
think it's inevitable I'm gonna pick up
a bit of weight in the offseason but I
think that's that's just healthy and
it's good for the body just to just to
recharge again yeah I'm in a long way a
long way from now but certainly I think
yeah if I mean it all depends on what
kind of roots what the what the
topography of the the racecourse is
going to look like if it's going to be
flat hilly but probably the time track B
could be a good goal for me there
[Applause]
no idea no idea yeah hopefully that
still get few a few years away from now
but I'd imagine that I'd still be
involved in the sport in in one way or
another
you
you